steve bannon has experienced the
weaponization of the justice system
firsthand he's the former white house
chief strategist
he has been targeted relentlessly by the
january 6th committee he joins us now by
phone to react to news
of the fbi raid on mar-a-lago steve um
happy to have you on the program have
you by phone here tonight what's your
immediate reaction
well well you know i gave this speech a
keynote address at the cattlemen's ball
at cpac on friday night i said where or
where the political and ideological war
and they've obviously weaponized
the justice department uh and this had
to be approved by ryan claim this had to
go up to the white house to be approved
absolutely anybody saying it didn't is
is a liar this had to go up the chain of
command through merrick garland
to ryan clean at least
and and ray and these guys but look
here's the thing
this is about pure power politics
they're absolutely scared to death about
trump it can't be mark elias
the guy who's laid out the entire effort
to steal the 2020 electrum the
transition integrity departure he's
tweeting right now all the us codes
about documents and they can have you
know make sure you can't run for federal
office again they're absolutely
petrified trump's going to announce the
next couple weeks win the republican
nomination win the white house now
here's what's in coming up on everybody
the house leaders right now need to step
up and recommit jim jordan full
investigation i think cutting off
appropriations to the fbi to get to the
bottom of this
okay this is this is going to continue
on the fbi right now is the gestapo
the fbi is the gestapo weathers out in
colorado putting a gold star mother like
tina peters in in in chains peter
navarro in chains it's absolutely
obscene this is an obscenity and we're
gonna have to fight fire with fire the
way to do it is when elections win them
overwhelmingly and then use the
appropriations process to choke down the
fbi and shut down the justice department
and get to the bottom of who approved
this this is this is so outrageous
i want to ask you this question steve um
you know i'm familiar with um i'm
familiar with your point of view i'm
familiar with the opinions you share on
war room i'm familiar with how deep you
fear the corruption has run within the
united states of america i'm curious i
said this earlier in the program
believing elections can change the
the place in which we sit today united
states of america is a very optimistic
point of view because
this corruption if it is partisan
corruption isn't relegated to the fbi we
saw 87 000 new irs agents have been
hired you can look at almost any federal
institution including the intelligence
community who dismissed hunter biden's
laptop as disinformation and you can say
to yourself this isn't one apparatus
this is not one department this is not
one election our problem is deeper
well you're a hundred percent correct
this is not a bankruptcy the let's say
that's not this is about the
administrative state this is about an
undemocratic apparatus bigger than the
yorkshire this is the administrative
state and they want to run things their
own way and they want to pick and choose
who actually runs and who actually wins
this is why it's incumbent upon look we
have two-thirds of the nations in back
of us hispanics african-americans
asian-americans it's now time to take
control of the house of representatives
with an overwhelming victory and then
act like we mean right the jim jordans
and people have to step up and kevin
mccarthy have to step up and say we're
going to have full investigations we're
going to choke him down incorporation
listen
we i got it steve this is a democratic
okay go ahead
i hate to cut you off steve we have uh
we have more information coming in as we
speak so i got to get to that steve it's
great to hear from you tonight
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight